la première grande surface réunionnaise
en 1961 raymond le sol ouvre le premier
supermarché de l'île sous l'enseigne
prisunic ce magasin est construit en
plein centre-ville de saint-denis dans
le quartier très commerçant du petit
marché
implanté en lieu et place d'une ancienne
fabrique de cigarettes
il occupe la totalité d'une parcelle ce
qui explique sa forme originale tandis
que la surface moyenne d'une boutique
chinois est alors de l'ordre de 60 m² ce
nouveau temple de la consommation
accueille ses clients sur une surface
totale de 3000 m² répartis en deux
vastes plateaux ou vers le rez de
chaussée est principalement dédié au
rayon textile
on y trouve également du bazar léger et
les incontournables effets scolaires lui
aussi composé d'un vaste plateau
modulable de 1500 mètres carrés
le premier étage est consacré aux
produits alimentaires de grands
rayonnages permettent d'accéder aux
produits en libre service ce qui
constitue une nouveauté tout comme la
ligne de caisse et le paiement au
comptant
à l'exception des trois l'argent très
réservé aux clients le magasin ne
dispose d'aucune ouverture sur
l'extérieur
l'aspect compact de ce vaste vaisseau de
béton tranche avec les vieux commerces
du centre-ville
tout comme ses élégantes lignes courbes
qui ne sont pas sans rappeler celle de
la maison fanucci située non loin de la
rue de paris
ancêtre de toutes les grandes surfaces
du lean cet édifice témoigne de
l'histoire de l'architecturé du 20e
siècle mais aussi de l'évolution des
modes de vie des réunionnais ces 50
dernières années